I do these interviews all the time so
I'll go on the street I'll talk to Matt
like I'll talk to them at random people
on the street random people in my living
room and I've had so many guys tell me
stories of girls doing this to them go
ahead and you your guys opinions favor a
certain side so when you go out on these
Ventures and you ask people you know
what you're looking for what you can put
you say we're rigging the game now no
not rigging the game but you're looking
for something can you that's why you're
going out there
I would say I would say I get more
people that disagree to be honest when I
go out than agree so I wouldn't say I'm
like rigging the game but